This experience will be
documented by
a mounted onboard camera.
Total solitude.
The terrible arrow injuries
I received to my left shoulder
are making it
more difficult to row,
but I'm not about to let that
ruin this relaxing sojourn
across a peaceful bay.
I took a few extra painkillers
and I gotta try to limit
my range of motion.
[chuckles]
[seagull caws]
Let's follow that bird.
I don't know if
it's the cool breeze
or the sound of lapping water
or the double dose of OxyContin
or the crisp salt air,
but I feel at peace in a way
that I haven't felt
in a long, long time.
Think I'm just gonna lie back
and enjoy it.
(Forrest voice-over)
But perhaps I had allowed myself
to feel too peaceful.
[snores]
[dramatic music]
♪ ♪
I've been asleep for six hours.
I think I must have drifted
out of the bay
and into the open ocean.
All right, well, I guess I just
gotta row back to shore
as fast as--
Oh, no, no, no.
Oh, where are the oars?!
Where are the oars?!
Oars!
Hello, here's my situation.
I have brought along
no food and no water
and no method
for signaling anyone,
and my cell phone here
doesn't get any service.
I am considering using one of
my shoelaces here
as a fishing line
and pieces of my wallet as bait.
And I only pray that
I am rescued
before that begins to seem like
a viable survival plan.
Jesus Christ.
Fish don't eat wallets.
(Forrest voice-over)
My review of making a wish
come true
had left me metaphorically
lost at sea.
Being literally lost at sea
was even worse.
There is a flashing red light
on the camera now,
which I assume means that
the battery is running low.
I would like to say something to
the love of my life,
my--my ex-wife, Suzanne.
Suzanne, I--
I'm pretty sure
I'm gonna die out here.
[static crackles]
[laughs]
Hello.
I do not know how many days
I have been at sea.
(Forrest voice-over)
I had been at sea for 96 days.
It is difficult to look at
this footage now,
but the mere fact of my survival
is a beautiful,
glorious miracle.
I've been swept into some kind
of a floating trash vortex
in the middle of the ocean.
I have been killing and eating
the sea birds
that perch on top of
the garbage.
I've been strangling them
and snapping their necks
with my hands.
And it's not a bad diet.
One of the things that I have
been blessed to find here
in this garbage island
is a battery that works
in this camera
so that I can continue
to talk to you
because I have had important
experiences
to share with you
about rowboats.
They are--
[static crackles]
Wow.
You were lost at sea
for a long time.
Yep.
[laughs]
I want to thank anybody
who has ever contributed
to the great Mid-Pacific
trash flotilla.
If you don't properly dispose
of your garbage,
you saved my life.